last week Jesse and I had the honor of
attending the 17th annual waiting for
wishes dinner in Nashville to help raise
money for some very special charities at
this dinner we waited the tables and it
was an amazing night
Jesse we haven't seen this yet
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't know how Jessie waters got
invited though do you want to tell us
anything about that I don't know either
it was a complete surprise to me
it's like my kid brother I got to take
them along with me everywhere
[Music]
I did wait tables years ago so we'll
figure this out maybe so what I dream
[Music]
I need brown bread they told me that
someone needs a brown bread I need brown
bread for a table for that brown bread
where do I get that it's in the kitchen
can i butter your roll do you like a lot
of butter
you probably just want the NFL players
Jasper word you better be putting money
in for me right stick nuts for everybody
$20 at night dig in all right medium
rare
I like the pocket square that's sharp
can I give you a little secret dress for
the job you want not for the job you
have we've got Jesse Watters and
obviously
Jessie that made us look like we were
the only celebrities they're bigger
celebrities you're a good waitress you
had plates going up your arm that's how
I got through college was a DJ she's for
Sonny I worked all I worked a lot but it
was a really wonderful event what'd you
think about meeting Kevin Carter it was
great and that young man who I gave a
tip about the pocket square he was the
the ambassador as a young kid and we
raised a lot of money for the
make-a-wish Foundation so it was
worthwhile
maybe Kimberly can come next year and
wait some tables as well Lana I'm not so
sure Greg is probably busy yes I'm very
good at dishes to bartenders why would
that be a great bar Cris Collinsworth
Bart's headed the entire thing I think
that was his way of getting out of
waiting tables also Tito Ortiz was there
that's right big deal it gave me a tip
on how to fight he said if you ever in a
fight waters punch him in the nose right
because it stuns them and then their
eyes don't want to be a blink it's weak
it's like he can punch and you can take
a punch
big chin I've never been to event like
that before where you had all sorts of
different people and the the patrons
they pay to come to the dinner but then
they have to pay extra for all sorts of
other things and then there's a live
auction that's right in someone want a
tour of Fox News and gonna watch five
shows now what what do they pay for that
I'm not gonna tell you no I know but and
and I think you took a cut of that and
of course it's gonna be worth it all
right thanks for inviting us